j'étais agressif finalement par un ami
même si son agresseur a été condamné à
plus d'un an de prison la peur n'a
jamais quitté cette femme au sixième de
sa peine il a été libéré pour aller
séjourner dans une maison de transition
à moins d'un kilomètre et demi de chez
elle c'est de la négligence vous avez
pas vérifié mon adresse que je trouve
quand même qui inhumain puis ça manque
de logique elle affirme avoir contesté
la décision de la Commission québécoise
de libération conditionnelle mais sans
succès à tous les jours bon soit change
de trajet
d'endroit où je vais à l'épicerie garder
tout ça donc si je vois quelqu'un qui
marche sur le bord de la rue ben c'est
sûr que je l'ai en alerte je vais un
véhicule qui ressemble à son véhicule je
vais en alerte je mets des lunettes
soleil je m'inqui capuchon quand je
conduis c'est c'est
c'est pas normal que j'aille faire ce
genre je retrouve comme mes bottines de
victimes puis là je me sens pas victime
d'un agresseur je me sens victime d'un
système qui est pas capable de protéger
les victimes la commission refuse de
commenter sa décision elle indique
qu'une victime peut s'exprimer par écrit
avant une audience et qu'elle sera prise
en considération autant que les droits
des victimes sont plus présents
maintenant dans tous les libérations
conditionnelles autant que la promotion
de ce droit là l'explication claire de
ce que ça veut dire et des impacts de ne
pas intervenir pour avoir je pense que
ça c'est pas toujours fait de façon
égale le cabinet du ministre de la
Sécurité publique se limite à dire que
c'est une priorité pour notre
gouvernement de protéger les victimes
c'est pourquoi nous avons mis en place
plusieurs mesures dont les bracelets
anti-rapprochement qui ont grandement
amélioré le sentiment de sécurité des
victimes un bracelet qui n'a toutefois
pas été imposé dans ce dossier
selon le CAVAC la grosseur pourrait
encore changer de maison de transition
et on a déjà vu dans le passé quand même
des situations être renversées parce que
justement l'impact était trop grand
auprès de la personne victime la femme
espère surtout que d'autres victimes
n'auront pas à subir le même sort
présentement je me retrouve dans une
situation qui est pire que je savais pas
porter plainte ici Geneviève Garon
Radio-Canada Montréal